we're so excited season 3 of unreal a  future things are about to get steamy  next season on unreal Thanks seven  braids [ __ ] the show's star constant  Zimmer shared her excitement with et  while promoting her new drama run the  tide alongside her co-star Taylor  Lautner I'm excited hey wait was bound  to happen yes and you know I'm excited  and I'm scared well Quinn and Rachel  amongst 25 eligible men is seems a  little dangerous right  I know fun and dangerous I know you're a  huge fan of The Bachelor would you be  down for a role why not yeah I love  working with Constance except that  wouldn't be your mother just completely  reverse the roles that we've played in  our past I would love to see you channel  your inner bad Chad the fact that I know  what you're talking about right now no I  know yes I watch The Bachelor Oh  are you joking of course I would I mean  I'll take them we'll take them I'll take  them all we'll take them all right  you